humankind has always had an unflagging
interest in exploring things around us
thus we've explored near the earth's
space constructed stations at the south
pole
and the times we have orbited the globe
are without number
but even today there are places on our
planet where man has never set foot
and they're right beneath us
science does not have any concrete facts
as to what may like tens of thousands of
meters
below the planet's surface in fact
samples of minerals extracted from deep
down are as valuable as those delivered
from celestial objects by spacecraft
but what prevents us from going as far
down as that and taking a look
and what has been revealed so far thanks
to the deepest
man-made well the cola super deep
borehole
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
people have attempted to drill hells on
the ground since the 13th century
the main purpose for such projects was
to take a close look at a diversity of
objects as yet not known to science that
could lie concealed in the depths of our
earth
for example several years ago a team of
geochemists from russia
france and germany discovered an
underground ocean dating back to the
archaean eon
it lies approximately 500 kilometers
deep
and its volume beats the overall amount
of water of all oceans on the planet's
surface
this discovery provided scientists with
more accurate data about the
peculiarities of our planet's formation
there is no doubt that these discoveries
would have been unthinkable without
super deep drilling projects
one of the best examples of these is the
kohler super deep borehole
which maintains the title of the deepest
in the world even a quarter of a century
after it was
captioning not
the available of its opening measures 92
centimeters
the drilling was carried out using the
ural mash 4a drilling rig
to be later superseded at 7263 meters by
ural mash 15000
whose mass was over 200 tons notably
took about 18 hours for the column to
travel
all the way up or down the chosen
drilling site was located 10 kilometers
to the west from the town of zapolarni
the borehole is situated in the
northeastern part of the baltic shield
and reaches archaean or bearing rocks
which are typically to be found in
ancient bedrocks of the continental
crust
the site is by all accounts ideal for
super deep drilling
as the kola peninsula is one of the few
continental places on earth that
contains no sedimentary rocks
and whose surface is comprised of
exceptionally ancient
rocks dating back approximately 3
billion years
unlike other major super-deep man-made
wells
made for the purposes of oil and gas
extraction works or geological surveys
the object of drilling the koala
borehole was specifically for scientific
purposes to pursue research
tasks its main objective was to confirm
theoretical models of the composition of
the lower layers of the earth's crust
and to find out more about the nature of
their transition to the earth's mantle
the explorers were also going to find
out about the bedrock composition of the
nicoliforous pechanga complex
identify the special features of
geological processes manifestations and
collect more data about the thermal
regime in the crust as well as about
deep water solutions
gases and rock composition the project
was also supposed to help
improve super deep drilling techniques
already existing at the time
and work out methods of complex
geological and physical studies of rocks
and doors at great depths
the drilling works started on may the
24th 1970
it was plane sailing down to 7 000
meters
as the drill was passing smoothly
through solid homogeneous granite rock
however having broken through the 7 000
meter mark
the drill entered less solid stratified
rocks and the well scarred and formed
voids
the column would then fail and the drill
would detach itself and fall when its
recovery was attempted
these failures became regular
occurrences and soon the wells structure
assumed a shape reminding one of a tree
with multiple branches broken off
on june the 6th 1979 the coalesce
superdeep borehole
beat the 9583 meter record previously
held by the bertha rogers oil
exploratory whale in oklahoma
and in 1983 the depth of the borehole
reached 12 066
meters after this record was beaten
the drilling was for a short time
suspended when the process was resumed
several months later
the first major failure occurred and the
drilling had to be started again from a
point just
seven kilometers deep by the year 1990
the new hole reached as far down as 12
262 meters however
following several other major failures
the process had to be aborted
with a borehole closing for good four
years later
it was initially expected that the kola
borehole would be instrumental in
discovering clear-cut transition from
granite to basalt
it should be mentioned that due to high
pressure and high temperatures
the granitrox physical properties were
dramatically affected
the granite samples extracted from the
well would often crumble due to the
sudden changes in the pressure
only extremely slow lifting of the drill
made it possible to extract a solid
piece of rock which enabled scientists
to make quite a few valuable conclusions
about the earth's deep interior
the major result of the geothermal
studies was information about
temperatures and well
the indicators proved to be much higher
than initially expected
closer to the surface the rate of
temperature increase accounted for 11
degrees per kilometer
at the depth of 2 kilometers it grew to
14 degrees per kilometer
at the depth from 2.2 to 7.5 kilometers
the temperature grew at the rate close
to 24 degrees per kilometer
eventually the temperature of 70 degrees
celsius was registered at the depth of
just 5 kilometers
and by 12 000 meters the temperature
rose to as much as 220 degrees celsius
new practical information about the
composition of the deepest parts of the
baltic shield
greatly complemented theoretical
suppositions
analysis of super deep rocks revealed
data considerably differing from
information known to science
before the launch of the super deep
borehole project
scientific results were also of
practical use
for example shallow copper and nickel
zones were discovered by geologists
and these rocks were suitable for
extraction
at the depth of nine and a half
kilometers an anomalous geochemical
layer of gold was discovered
gold concentration accounted for up to a
gram per 1 ton of the rock
and even though gold mining is hardly
feasible at that greater depth
the very existence of the gold carrying
layer as well as its properties
allowed modeling evolution processes of
these metals with more precision
the length record of the coalish
superdeep borehole was beaten only
recently
and that only by wells drilled for
large-scale oil and gas extraction
one of these is the oil well known as
maersk oil
bdo4a it was drilled in 2008 and is 12
290 meters long
to date the z42 chivo well is the
longest well on earth
extending as far down as twelve thousand
seven hundred meters
however the koala borehole remains the
deepest
man-made well
in addition to the borehill's
record-breaking features it also boasts
unique history
which over the years has been shrouded
by innumerable legends and mysterious
myths
many of them were prompted by various
failures the scientists had to face
but were not always able to identify
what had caused them
for example in 1995 an explosion of
inexplicable nature originated at the
deepest point of the well
and the drilling had to be stopped the
cause of this phenomenon has never been
identified
the supervisor of the operations david
miranovich guberman confirmed that a
bizarre noise had been heard
prior to the explosion interestingly
several days later nothing of the kind
took place at the same depth
it is possible that the cores lay in a
failure of the drill itself
or else an encounter with a substance
not yet known to science
it is hardly unfeasible as such deep
layers of the globe still remain almost
unexplored
the coalesc superdeep borehole has
traveled only a minuscule portion of the
whole way to the center of the earth
the full distance is 6371 kilometers
the scientists working at the well hoped
to get to the mantle at least
but to achieve this it would have taken
another 30 or 40 kilometers
but even as it is what they did manage
to carry out
borders on fantasy to this day not a
single apparatus has gone that deep
underground
today geology is advancing on a par with
space exploration
and research involving drilling is
comparable to space exploration
using telescopes which is so familiar to
us
geologists cherish some ambitious plans
too
and while one part of the scientific
community concerns themselves with how
to reach other planets
another part studies the makeup of our
own earth
and is busy figuring out how to get as
far as its center
you